a primeira
notícia pra vocês eu passei os últimos
dois dias e entrevistando jovens para o
sistema de bolsas da fundação estudar e
e fico impressionado todo ano como como
jovens estão melhorando assim a
qualidade das pessoas é um espetáculo
que ontem jovem de 17 anos aceito nas
melhores faculdades dos estados unidos e
espetaculares geralmente ea é a melhor
notícia é que hoje em dia muitos desses
jovens estão interessados em política e
oi para o setor público né
na minha época ninguém queria ir para o
governo quer dizer e agora eu estive
roger dá três semanas atrás também num
seminário para brasileiros e no final a
um jovem já convidaram aqueles que
queriam ir para o setor público para
subir no palco para tirar um retrato
para daqui a dez anos o olhar quem tinha
realmente feito alguma coisa no setor
público e subindo os 40 jovens
brasileiros nas melhores escolas
americanas
então eu acho que o brasil vai melhorar
quando esse pessoal voltar esse pessoal
tiverem cargos importantes e assim né e
substituem um o pessoal que está aí
agora né
bom vamos lá minha a minha palestra
bom como eu invisto muito em educação
acreditando que esta é a melhor forma de
gerar maior igualdade de oportunidade
para todos
acho que vocês imaginam que a minha
própria educação tenha sido formal
estruturada e bem planejada
como vocês verão não foi bem assim
mas vamos a minha história eu nasci no
rio e dos meus 76 anos morei 1 50 anos
aqui no rio casa então eu sou sou
realmente carioca
vou falar um pouco da grande influência
do rio positiva e negativa na minha
formação
espero que vocês na proteste em algum
proveito do meu aprendizado e que sirva
para os que têm filhos e para a futura
escola e leva
incorporar algo do meu aprendizado na
sua filosofia de ensino
basicamente fui educado com muita
liberdade autonomia praticando esportes
com a necessidade de me adaptar a
convivência com gente diversa assumindo
riscos ea constante necessidade de tomar
decisões ou seja tive um grau de
liberdade independência e situações de
me virar por conta própria maior do que
a maioria dos meus colegas
acho que essa liberdade foi um fator
positivo na minha vida
do lado negativo faltou disciplina
melhor conhecimento das ciências exatas
e uma visão de longo prazo
fatores que só pôde tentar corrigir mais
tarde né
menciona a seguir algumas memórias
morava no leblon
aos cinco anos me botaram na escola
americana
usualmente teria ido para uma escola
alemã meu pai da suíço e minha mãe filha
de suíços mas como a segunda guerra
tinha acabado com a derrota dos alemães
foi para uma escola americana entre os
meus colegas de rua e esporte eu me
sentia diferente todos estudavam em
escolas brasileiras e eu numa
estrangeira
aprendi inglês sendo o que se tornou uma
grande vantagem mais tarde tive muito
mais acesso no mundo por falar em inglês
bem a escola americano era conhecida por
sua disciplina mas em compensação o
quadro de professores era divertir
diverso e divertindo
meu professor de matemática e física era
um grupo fugido do comunismo
o dia do cas educação física que dobrava
como professor de biologia era um russo
um galã da escola também fugido do
comunismo
a professora de história fugiu dos
nazistas
minha professora no primeiro ano mais
tarde fundou o chapeuzinho vermelho
escola que ficou famosa no rio
a professora de francês veio para o
brasil perseguindo sua paixão
nunca casou mas viveu até 106 anos e
havia os americanos em geral eram
americanos de passagem pelo rio de
janeiro que a iam lá ensinar na escola
fazendo um bico né
então era uma escola cheia de
professores amadores mas uma diversidade
incrível de pessoas entre os alunos a
variedade nacionalidades era grande
também
somado aos professores permite uma
interação com culturas diversas
havia pouca rigidez e disciplina na
escola
o ambiente livre gerava oportunidade ser
criativo de se virar por conta própria
qualidades que certamente foram
fundamentais no meu futuro como
empreendedor
a interação com diversas culturas tornou
mais fácil a minha expansão para o
exterior nos negócios
anos mais tarde lembro com saudade desta
época do rio de janeiro com 18 anos eu
podia ir para a escola sozinho a pé ou
de bicicleta e aprendizado maravilhoso
para um jovem desta idade poderá andar
sozinho na rua e risco de seqüestro
roubo nem passava pela minha cabeça
o perigo maior para os meninos de
territórios diferentes que ameaçavam
caso que usássemos áreas que ele
considerava em considerar sem deles
a solução era mudar a rotina ou ir de
bicicleta na minha infância o esporte é
um foco importante eu jogava tênis onde
aprendi a competir perder aprendendo a
treinar à terra disciplina que me
faltava na escola ter mais autocontrole
e também como avaliar adversários desde
cedo participava de torneios pelo brasil
afora viajava sozinho e tinha de me
virar uma riqueza de experiências na
formação de um jovem aos 12 anos comecei
a freqüentar o arpoador
como já vi 12 outros jorge
é o jorge francês jorge grande eu passei
a ser o jorge americano porque estudava
na escola americana
comecei a surfar e a pescar de mergulho
na época o arpoador era o centro da
juventude avançada mas drogas ainda não
tinha aparecido por lá chegaram órfã dor
anos mais tarde eu como era atleta
competia muito no tênis sempre estive
imune às bebedeiras festanças ou drogas
as viagens de pesca para búzios
era uma aventura pegávamos uma barca
para niterói um ônibus para cabo frio e
outro ônibus para búzios
raramente a logística funcionava bem e
muitas vezes sobrava vamos em lugares
inesperados né
surfar no arpoador e viagens para pescar
de mergulho em cabo frio e angra eram
oportunidade excelente de aprender a
liberdade que meus pais me davam me
obrigava a tomar decisões e solucionar
problemas mesmo que fossem pequenos
estudar eu estudava ler também havia
mais gostava mesmo era de ação tênis
surfe e aventuras
fico triste quando penso que hoje em dia
é difícil é impossível no rio para
qualquer criança de oito anos ea pé
sozinho para a escola ou frequentar o
arpoador aos 12 anos esta necessidade de
adaptação e de dar com experiências e
pessoas variadas na minha vida na minha
infância foi um fator muito construtivo
no meu aprendizado
minha educação carioca contribuiu para
que eu me tornasse um é eterno otimista
aliás conheço mais otimistas bem
sucedidos do que pessimistas
para mim o mundo tinha problemas mas era
limbo
estava sempre melhorando gerava
oportunidades excepcionais e as meninas
do arpoador e do colégio são paulo eram
maravilhosas
bom se essas minhas experiências de
liberdade não são aplicáveis no mesmo
formato como é
acho que eu pude ter
recomendo muito aos pais a platéia que
encontrem outras formas de proporcionar
liberdade e opções de escolha aos filhos
os o mundo está mudando cada vez mais
rápido e crianças sem a possibilidade de
experimentar e resolver estarão em
desvantagem
eu tenho muita preocupação com os pais
que sempre estão muito preocupados com a
educação formal dos filhos e das notas e
e assim né acho que tem muito mais uma
boa educação do que o estudo formal né
então acho que a criança tem que ter
porque tem que correr os riscos têm que
fazer bobagens tem que errar é assim que
ela aprende né
aos 17 anos fui para a roça eu deixei
meu avô a dor querido para sempre
harvey foi uma dureza para um carioca na
praia que nunca havia estado nos estados
unidos apesar de ter estudado na escola
americana mas tinha aprendido a me virar
e me adaptar me virei e me formei sem
brilho aos 20 anos como me formei antes
da minha classe
nunca peguei o meu diploma em 2014 num
evento em hollywood decidiram entregar o
diploma que eu nunca tinha pego a droga
estava lá
eu acho bom a até até que eu gostei de
receber com 53 anos de atraso porque eu
não peguei antes não sei direito mas
talvez por uma certa implicância com a
educação formal demais né não ter raiva
de seja muito rígida cada um estudo que
quer por lá mas para um carioca que
ligado criado com pouca disciplina todo
aquele aparato universitário burocrático
é irritante
sinto muito em educação e aprender mas
em linhas gerais me preocupa
burocratização e rigidez dos sistemas
existentes como descrevi anteriormente
dou muito valor à experiência a
oportunidade de tomar decisões ea errar
para aprender conta robert para pena
mencionar que duas das maiores estrelas
recentes pessoas inovadoras no ramo de
negócio chegaram a frequentar a
faculdade mas não se formaram o bill
gates que o marketing do clube
resolveram que tinham coisas mais
importantes para fazer o aprender em vez
de se formar em roupas né
depois de roubar e passei um ano jogando
tênis na europa o suficiente para saber
que não era aquilo que eu queria fazer
apesar de gostar de jogar até hoje mas
pelo menos joguei em algum dos torneios
mais conhecidos como embolando o longa
foi a taça deles retornando ao rio me
juntei um grupo de aire vídeos que havia
fundado uma financeira mais um baita
aprendizado falimos depois de quatro
anos gostava da dinâmica do mercado
financeiro continua no mercado e juntei
ao novo empreendimento uma distribuidora
de valores
não foi um fracasso mas a sociedade não
prosperou comprar a minha participação e
me retirei da sociedade em 1971 com 31
anos juntei todas as minhas poupanças e
monteiro garantia já fazia dez anos que
eu tinha me formado já viu já havia
passado por duas experiências
frustrantes mas finalmente as coisas
começaram a andar
será que se eu tivesse tido mais
disciplina mais planejamento de longo
prazo eu teria escapado dos fracassos
é possível que sim mas por outro lado
meu desejo de liberdade e disposição
para correr riscos
me mantinha na rota de tentar inovar
sonhar grande em vez de me contentar com
um bom salário e segurança
em 1971 tive uma grande sorte havia
montado a corretora garantia para operar
em bolsa mas mal compreende corretora ea
bolsa despencou 70%
meu negócio previsto evaporou
na mesma época o banco central decidiu
criar um mercado de títulos
governamentais um novo negócio que abriu
oportunidade para muitos jovens do
mercado financeiro de se provar em até
então a sorte tinha sorrido para mim em
termos das ondas suicidas que havia
surfado dos ataques de tubarão que eu
havia escapado dos assaltantes que havia
sobrevivido e agora só está me dando uma
oportunidade excepcional do mundo de
eu pessoalmente acho que a sorte é o
resultado de muito suor mas tem um bom
amigo que sempre diz que a sorte passa
pela frente de todo mundo
alguns agarram outros não foi o que fiz
agarrei roupa marca que virou um negócio
excepcional para a construção de outros
negócios
os negócios do garantia e um bem mas a
sociedade começou novamente a fraquejar
meus traços meus sócios ordinários que
iriam ser sócios mas não queriam
trabalhar
tive de comprá-los substituí los por
jovens promissores
depois de apanhar nas primeiras
sociedades
comecei a melhorar em termos de
sociedade e associados mas sempre tendo
de aprender através das dificuldades e
com a disposição para mudar ou tentar
novamente
se tivesse tido uma educação muito
rígida e informal
dificilmente iria me ajustado às
necessidades constantes de mudança e
adaptação
nesta mir nesta época minha vida com
infância de muita liberdade disposição
para coisas novas e riscos começou a dar
certo
em 1983 compramos o controle das lojas
americanas meus colegas do mercado
financeiro que ganhava um rio
o dinheiro com juros altos acharão que
estávamos loucos pra que fazer comprar
uma empresa quando os juros são tão bons
em 1989 compramos a grama
ela era tão maior do que nós que nos
acusaram de sermos testa de ferro de
grupos internacionais a maioria de um
dos meus colegas do mercado financeiro e
suas empresas desapareceram
nós com ativos mais sólidos mais tarde
continuamos por aqui sempre prontos para
melhorar e inovar e tentar fazer de
maneira diferente de educação carioca
teve algumas falhas como estudei em
escola americana nunca fui muito bom em
ciências exatas
faltou disciplina em geral no início da
carreira e visão de longo prazo
o carioca não é um adepto de muita
disciplina visão de longo prazo fui
tentando corrigir isso ao longo dos anos
em resumo acredito numa boa educação
formal mas não a deixe matar o
aprendizado da rua ou praia à disposição
de errar de decidir de inovar e de
tentar de novo se houver uma derrota
pelo caminho
meu aprendizado carioca teve falhas mas
filó
infelizmente gerou oportunidades que
foram agarradas e com continuam carioca
otimista bem humorado e querendo sempre
melhorar
obrigado